i'd like to welcome to pi data global
2021 i'll give our like to give a warm
welcome to our
speaker
speaker
adam who is dr adam
i'm sorry if i misprint
how do you pronounce your problem
i know that it's card sheets
he's an
astrophysicist working at national
center for nuclear research and a
lecture of natural language processing
at cognitive studies master program at
faculty of
psychology at warsaw
in the
2018 he was at the center of
gravitational wave astrophysics at the
university of texas rio grande valley
valley following that he defended his
doctorate doctorate at the national
center for nuclear research he took part
in the first detection of gravitational
waves by the international ligo virgo
project
as a phd student he was an intern at
facebook inc
and since this is
his talk i'd like to pass the mic over
to him
in your head adam
thank you very much
okay so my talk will be about usage of
python it's it will be
i'm an astrophysicist so i usually work
with a lot of with a lot of data and
and stuff but i also interested in using
python for every every day
for a live
for everyday
stuff but one thing that came to our
attention recently with with me and some
some of my
workers was that if we if we have for
example a law
and we try to analyze it
the the stupid question we would like to
there is a need for a cured kindergarten
at the you at the new university campus
how many documents we need to read to
make sure that the place that is that is
chosen
uh would fulfill
requirements
and the problem is that if we
go through the
most of the legal systems
if we try to answer the question
in
france or in
poland or probably in ireland we need to
go to through the multiple documents
it's not only the the one uh one
documents uh
that would say okay so so the building
has to get the certain requirements but
probably in the provisional acts for the
fire
man's and
uh
for or a fire station there there will
be information okay you can you can
assume that the
building is safe
if
the there is a certain criteria made so
for for the other uh services that need
to approve the kindergarten as a
building there will be another set of
requirements and then you can end up
with reading almost
a big chunk of the law
and
this is a bit of a hypothetical question
but very similar one of my friends uh
she was opening a kindergarten in the
in the buildings office buildings next
next to the offices of the new open
company
uh
but
what i would like to show in this talk
is uh how we
might
try to uh
get a better grasp of the law using nlp
and python and
big data and try what we can get by this
analysis this this would be uh
more about
showing some ideas and
some work that has been done in the
tutorial on the uh nlp data but
how to how to deal with the law because
we are working mostly on the irish and
polish law but
but i would like to show some ideas how
we can we can use python and its ability
to process text very nicely to do that
okay
what is the law it's some kind of a
system of rules and guidelines which
which are enforced through the social
institution governor behavior this is a
wikipedia definition
if we look on them
if we if we start looking on
uh
how
the loc look like this is a part of the
polish law i i know that the most of you
speak english but certain patterns you
can you can you can see like for example
that
this is a reference to some internal
document
there might be some references if you if
you see something like that it might be
a reference uh to
some internal part of the act so some
kind of an article or
a point of whatever
so this is
so that then you have a logical part of
this text
here you have the articles here we have
some points uh of article that was
starting before and here we have the
information that we would like to
access the
external document
so for the civil law
it's which we have mostly in europe uh
we rely on the texts that are that that
has been uh go through the parliament
than on them
there is no binding uh
way of the court verdicts uh with with
some exception of supreme court and
constitutional tribunal
this is the the only two exceptions the
most of the
countries in european union
uh in the u.s and uk
common law system where the court cases
played a major role is a bit on the
difference so rest of the europe
apart from iran
ireland and uk it's on the different
side
so the the problem the other problem
that we have with the law but it's not a
continuous text
the reference inside the documents in
reference to the external part and what
is more
intriguing there is
incoming external references that could
not be
when when you read the text of the of
the law that is published on the
ornamental website there is no
information about the incoming uh
reference to the to the
to the certain
article which might change
uh what what that means especially
sometimes there are also no not name
references so you you might have the
article in know that if there is uh
this is some kind of a transition law
from poland if there is uh anywhere
mentioned the uh
militia it you you need to understand
that it's meaning the police and
uh police so there is a substitution
which do not reference to any particular
act but it's referencing to many acts so
the graph is a
representation of a set of objects where
some pairs of objects are connected by
the links and
notice that this is exactly this case we
have some references we have the notes
we have the logical parts so basically
the law can be expressed as a graph in
fact the multi graph because the
possibility of multiple connections uh
the same note
getting from from the from the from the
note it's so it's safer to say that it's
multi-ground but
i would rather use
refer it as a graph so
notes it would be a logical parts of the
text and you can have a top note which
is a chapter of some kind of a law and
then you go to the articles points sub
points uh
liters
so so the
characters and stuff like that
and the address it's a connection
between the logical parts noteparent
connection and connection to the
external documents so what are the
sources of data if you would like to
just grab it and and and get the data so
in in poland it's uh
jimmy costa for monitor possibly but
it's only in pdf no api so
nothing interesting but there is a
source of the law which uh
internet
system of uh legal acts which have the
update
and
allows to get getting getting the data
in ireland for example there is an irish
statue book there is no ap whatsoever
but there is uh
but
but it's you can get the xml but it's
not so easy because you you need to get
the full arc you need to go over the
several xml pages so it's
but they keep the certain formats so so
this one one
thing there was there used to be
something which is called the bundesbit
which
you can you can get the german law
in the git but there was no comment from
uh beyond 2013
so so this is pretty much that but if
you would like to
analyze it it's uh it might be
interesting interesting stuff for you to
do and it's easy to just make a clone
and and you can
you can get the data it would be funny
if somebody would
just put the pull request to change the
actual law to this one but unfortunately
nothing like that happened uh
so uh if we look on the on this example
act we uh
here we have the
some kind of an act from uh from polish
law and we have the article which have
this certain uh
subpoints so
we have a five sub points to the first
article
we have the second and third one
so
if we go here we have if we try to
dissect a certain act we have the name
of the act some kind of an introduction
which
why we would like to to to to push
through this law and there is some
information about the reference the
external act especially the changes to
the external acts
so uh if we go to the articles there are
certain subpoints and those subpoints
would refer to one another there is one
uh on the fourth sub points we mentioned
the the point uh
in the four points we might mention the
point two and three
so and this is income some
way uh defined form
here we have uh the
uh the reference to that the first point
from that there is no no text uh just
after the act or here is only a little
there is there is no text after the
article starting and here we have on the
article three we have okay we have some
some kind of a definition
then we starting to to do the reference
to the
uh the to the later notes so
basically we can have some kind of a a
graph it's not a tree certainly it's not
a tree because there uh there is a
possibility
which is not shown here
that
the node could reference the the the
upper
some some other nodes so we can we can
have from the lower
no note reference somewhere up
uh
so
you sit and if we would like to try to
start processing uh law in that way we
get some our hands on some
raw text
the stack that we were using it was it
was python with network x library
mongodb as a data storage and
to
get the information
about references inside the document
because references between the documents
are easy to grasp and sometimes if you
have the law in html you got the
references just like that
uh but
to make the reference inside you need
regular expressions
but also with addition of some fuzzy
logic
bear in mind that the law is written by
humans for humans
so there will be a lot of mistakes
for example bracket that is never
closed uh some quotation that never ends
and stuff like that so uh fuzzy logic
allows us to to say okay there is
something committed but it still seems a
valid link so let's let's get it
and jeffy was was our visualization uh
engine at some uh at some point uh we
also some key plots that we are using in
publication we were
just doing the post processing in adobe
indesign so how it how how would the
pipeline do
work so first you get the data through
the rp then you get the raw text then
you do the passing once more because if
it's if it's not fast and then you do
the linking so you save to the database
a link link version of a of a text
uh
and
for for the password if we try to make
make a full parcel to to get the the
capture call structure you you just need
to
you start with the header then you get
get the section which are optional
and and you have
you also put chapters uh chapters are
optional sections are optional but the
stuff that you are ending up with are
articles and sometimes you get the
appendixes and then you have sub
articles uh numbering subnumbering so so
this is you you are just getting getting
down with with all the
uh all the stuff there was a question on
the chat if there was a
circular references yeah in the auto
ship law i think article 50 refines or
51 we find something like that
uh so so this it's it's possible
sometimes
uh if we are getting through the act so
so this is how if you if you read the
text of polish constitution and you pass
it to the uh
it's it's a pretty straightforward
vortex the the constitution tax in
general uh
it has to be understandable
uh by
by everyone by by all of the citizens so
there is not too much legal language
some kind of
the laws that would like to keep in our
country is the same with the us
constitution the same with irish
constitution
with polish ones so this is not very
very complicated one document with not a
lot of references there are only certain
references if you if you wonder what
it's here here is the
information about
freedoms
in the country it's the second second
chapter
and here you have the article uh
233 which is very deeply connected to
many of it and
it's for the time of war which which
freedoms during the time of war or civil
unrest could be
evoked for some time
this is this is the the one of the
articles here it's some some articles
about the
what are the
sources of the law there's about the
president
and here is the about the courts
so so this is the courts are linked with
uh
with the sources of the law and and
other things so there is there is not
much connections here it's pretty
straightforward
uh
but this is the text which is
which is not a direct
law it's some kind of should govern the
the
of the law but then if we go to the core
the one of the most important acts in
polish law which is a value other tax or
the tax that you pay when you buy
something in the shop for example uh
you see the night marriage view
because
the current version was established in
in 2004
and
comparing with the constitution there is
a lot of highly connected notes
and it's very frequently updated even
for up to six times a year in poland and
executive art
could be very short-lived even up to
four to five weeks that we found during
the analysis which
which was extremely short even for a
polisher which is really unstable
and here you you can see something which
is
which we call transmission belt or
triggering points because there are
certain points that are very deeply
connected from
almost every chapter this chapter it's
almost inside the circle which is uh
which since when when you can lower the
tax this is the this is the chapter that
a lot of many court cases
uh in polish
administrative courts
uh went on because it's uh not really to
understand if something changes here or
here it might influence also those arts
so
if you change any of the notes
in this inside the circle then you might
propagate the change
in the load to different different nodes
and for example if you're running
business and you you rely on certain of
those nodes to become stable you don't
only need to track those you need to
also track those
the other the other group
so so the changes might not be local in
this case
uh
yeah and and putting too much law in in
one place it could be could be deadly uh
to be a little bit deadly because
sometimes if something is removed it
could propagate like for example
one one point was uh
mentioned by the by the irish as un
unconstitutional but they could only
ruled out the lowest
lowest possible note which was the uh
name of the substances that are in liga
which
made
drugs legal in iran for one day
okeydoke so uh this is this some kind of
historical grabbing
and
and this is uh
this is for from the
the period between the wars and you can
if you if you do the whole legal system
you can you can find uh the certain
parts
regulating healthcare
country
governments communication which was a
bit
and also railways which was in in
during that time in poland it was a
state within the state it was the
backbone of transportation so it was uh
almost self-governing bodies but for
example country government strength and
industry was quite close to one another
um
this is the how the the polish
law looks like in 2014 so there was
quite a lot of notes quite
many connections and this is the irish
law which was the common law which was
much more
compact here it's more than 40 000
active points there's only 3 000 points
which not
3 000 points that were over the course
of 90 years uh so tax law it's quite a
big one
social welfare industry and play it's
detached but social industry and labor
and country governments are quite close
to tax criminal law it's somewhere
far away
from uh from the attacks
so there is certain structures that
might appear which is highly connected
notes clicks uh tree-like structures or
even a fan structures uh which which was
com this from the irish law which
shows the amendments to the act in the
common law this this structure is is
very common in
in common law system like uk
uk or ireland so the number number of
facts
it shows how
the common law thinks to be
much much more dense and easier to
govern the country and
uh
with the with the law which is um not a
common law but but civil law the the
number of acts for example in poland
could be extremely high
um
yeah so
data science uh science and in law could
be it's it's always safe not really in
for example if you if you try to link uh
do the date analytics on the judges in
france it's uh you can get five years
for that
if you if you target certain judge and
which arguments are killed
learning it's it's it's forbidden
uh
for plus
i'm i'm just going through the to the
end of the talk um
it's uh
if you look on the for the redundancy
okay
i it seems that i need to finish right
now
uh if you look on the redundancy you can
there is a multiple definition of doing
business and you can get grab it from
from each
act and compare it how similar it is
uh
there was in the document if you look on
those definitions there is no
way to link those there is no the text
is similar but they are not linked if
you change something you can change it
for a certain part of the law but it
starts
uh starts to be unified by using the
reference to the the one common
definition
okay though what what what thing we
would like to do with nlp law question
answering but there is a need to of a
good data set obstructive question
answering the same but we need the data
which usually the legal companies
have
which is not not openly available uh
checking of the two fragments if they're
opposite there are no production ready
tools to to see if the
if there is
if we can can com say that
two parts of the law are contradictory
and what are the difference between the
the fragment the same situation is here
so there is it's a quite unexplored area
so the ultimate question with uh
one of the questions that that we
would like to answer is
what will happen if we change the one
one line of the law how how fast it
would it would spread it not necessarily
means that if there is a connection they
are dependent
this is another tool that that has to be
developed to achieve see if there is a
dependency
but at this point
we are assuming that there is
uh
so we we can process the law uh using
nlp uh
and python to some extent and
based on that we can
create the tools that will allow the
citizens control over the law and
dictation of the legislation but the the
biggest problem analyzing legal system
are the sources of data uh what is more
the good law is crucial for economical
growth it's crucial for stable growth
and sustainable growth so this this kind
of important one one more argument why
we when we are trying to
uh
that we are trying
to to
get this
try to analyze the link is that if we
can
squash the parts of the text that are
relevant to case we can we can use
question answering and we can try to
analyze it by using ai and
and also the
using the methods that we already
developed in nlp
so
thank you very much for your attention
and i would be happy to uh to answer any
questions comments
all right we've got one uh
from tom oh i think this is more of a
statement but i'll go ahead i think that
the reference connection between
documents do not always imply that
those documents are mutually
interdependent uh
what are your thoughts on that
yeah it's it's not necessary that there
is there is a dependency between that
but so
as i mentioned there there is a need to
develop a classifier which
to see if the relation means some
dependency or
there might be an influence
so this is this is uh this is one one
yeah that's that's right that did not
always mean the dependency but in many
cases it does in the most
of the cases that that we have there is
i would say that
in case of polish law from
probably it would mean it would be 10 of
the cases that it would there will be no
dependency in the most cases there there
is
um
there is uh
aggregating more
yeah
the the one
with the aggregation of more specific
data set for the for the users that i
mentioned the more advanced users
um
the best source it would be
it would be some
uh either the legal companies which
would not make it public or pro
state prosecutors
and in these cases
it might be possible to make it make it
that's open data especially for the old
cases
that are
100 years old or or
50 years old
so then then we could could possibly
access this data
unless unless there are some legal
companies would like to make it opens or
non-profit organization of lawyers
this this might be another source of
data to assemble it fast
it's possible to see something
synthetically assembled such a data set
but it would
need a lot of
skilled manpower to do that all right
there's another uh
question i believe
custis sorry if i get that wrong any
ideas on how to approach
on aggregating the more specific data
sets for more advanced
applications such as you mentioned
there was there was a mention about the
dependency hierarchy of the sun laws and
in the most countries it's there is such
hierarchy that that we get the
constitution then probably if if the
country is a part of the european union
then european union then treaties
international treaties then european
union law then the local law so there is
some kind of a hierarchy but
it's not always
officially stated
sometimes it's a customary
with the fairness of the law
it would
be
it would be hard to make make such
analysis but if if the law is easy to
understand it i would say that it's you
can say something about fairness in this
case because you don't need the specific
legal advice but um
but with with the fairness it would be
it would be really hard to uh
to judge it to fully judge it at some
extent we can use the nlp tools but
uh to to see if if there are
if there is a measurement between the
both parties if they are equal
but in general not uh not
not
it would be a very hard question to
answer using the nlp and
python data processing uh definitely
thank you thank you so much for your
talk and i'd like to wish you well for
the rest of the conference and please
have a wonderful day